hey best buy let me say this to you
okay every night you want to email me
around midnight 1am
first of all your stores aren't even
open at that time
have you thought about that second of
all what do you think i'm gonna do
you think i'ma get out of bed
with my stuffed animal or with a girl
maybe
but you think i'm gonna get out of bed
to go look at one of your xeroxers or
look at one of your 71-inchers
it's 1am
and you guys are beating me over the
damn screen face
with your you know we got toasters we
got
mortal you know mortal warrior 60.
you know join the club join the group
don't you want this oven i'm
asleep
i don't need an oven while i'm sleeping
all right i'm trying to get some rest
i'm not trying to get a deal best buy
so you best believe me
when i tell you to limit a alone in
emails
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one